well the big breakthrough album for me
would be the joker right i mean that's
uh yeah that was that was the first
success that was like um that was like a
viral
tune that had nothing to do with the
record company it just went out
did you write that quick the joker was
just a song
that you know it was one of those pieces
of music i had had that i really liked
the guitar parts
how long had you had that piece of music
in your head yeah six months or
something and i had you know i mean i
was working on kind of like i'm rocking
me and the joker and take the money and
run and they
could switch the lyrics to one to the
other right
you know it's very easy to do and the
joker just sort of got
came into focus and didn't really know
what we were doing
you know it was just cool and this live
guitar part was neat and i liked the
harmony and i was
very happy that finally i was getting
like the 12 string sound i wanted and
when you played for the record company
are they excited did they think you've
hit into something i played it for this
group of people that were like in the
promotion department at about one
o'clock in the afternoon and this one
kid said hey
i i think the joker's a hit and i said
listen man don't worry about singles
just try and get some albums in the
stores and the cities
i'm playing in here's a list of 60
cities i'm leaving this afternoon and
when i got
back it was number one all over the
world you know it was like that finally
like that had to be a rush right because
that puts you on the map you know you're
never happy right hard i mean like i
remember
driving to the fox theater in oakland to
do a show because we were still playing
you know little 2000 seat things nothing
had changed yeah because we had booked a
tour
in advance right and uh i was driving i
was back
we were finishing up this part of the
tour and and i was listening to the
radio and the joker was on
four radio stations so i was pissed off
because it wasn't on the fifth station
in san francisco
yeah i mean yeah what what was the hook
he came up with for the joker like what
was what first came to you what did you
hear in your head
well you know it was all after the fact
what i was doing i didn't know what i
was doing i
was just playing it and i loved the way
it sounded and i loved the chorus so the
chorus was really great
the slide guitar solo was great the
whistle was really great the
super laid back kind of so just
you know this character who is just like
you know
so lazy and laid back it was really
uh you know a great thing and and on
you know more singles after that i mean
we got better and better and better at
it would you do a little bit of the uh
of the joker the joker
[Music]
some people call me the space cowboy
[Music]
some come in the gangster love
[Music]
some people call me maurice
cause i speak for the pompetes of love
people talk about me baby
yeah say i'm doing you wrong doing it
don't you
worry no dollar no don't worry
cause i'm right here right here right
here right here at home
cause i'm a pickup i'm a grinner
i'm
[Music]
[Applause]
and i'm a joker i'm a smoker i'm a
midnight talker
[Music]
you got it beautiful that's a nice song